Justice League didn't hold back in any
of the big moments we had a planet
threatening disaster a team of
superheroes determined to stop it and a
good old-fashioned race between Superman
and flash now that justice has been
served on the big screen we're doing
justice to the little moments and small
details you may have missed in Justice
League spoilers ahead crisis cameo early
in the film you may have caught that
newspaper headline for the metropolis
Post asking if a bunch of fallen heroes
returned to their own planets what you
may not have noticed was the smaller
headline beside the main story citywide
crisis in the DC Universe a crisis is
kind of a big deal and DC doesn't throw
the c-word around casually it started in
Justice League of America number 21 with
the crisis on earth one storyline in the
very next issue there was crisis on
earth to later 1985's game-changing
crisis on Infinite Earths story arc with
the entire multiverse in peril various
crises even popped up after that like
Infinite Crisis identity crisis and
final crisis basically most of DC Comics
history has been defined by crises so
name dropping the word in a DC EU movie
is definitely a piece of fanservice
smooth finish for the majority of the
movie cyborg had a notably different
look than he does in the comics most
versions of cyborg in the comics have a
smooth aerodynamic exterior in Justice
League however cyborg had sharp edges
sticking out everywhere like a sentient
pile of cutlery but at the end of
Justice League Vic uses his growing
control over the mother box tech to give
himself a makeover ditching the Robocop
2 vibe for a polished Chell lifted
straight from the comics and while we're
on the topic of cyborgs booyah
throughout cyborgs run on Teen Titans
and Teen Titans go Sparky has had one
distinguishing catchphrase it takes most
of Justice League to get there but right
at the end he drops his big line giving
at least some of the audience a reason
to get out of their seats with a smile
if you've never come across cyborg in
any form before Justice League you'd
never know what all the fuss was about
Mira
amber herds character Mira didn't get a
ton of screen time in Justice League but
the costume designers definitely paid
homage to Mira's comic sward
from a crown to her green scaled armor
the likeness is exact
unfortunately Justice League left the
fate of Mira and the nature of a
relationship with Aquaman up in the air
but since Amber Heard is slated to star
in the upcoming Aquaman film it looks
like we'll get to see what finally
happens with the future queen of
Atlantis red sky of doom leading up to
the climax of Justice League
Steppenwolf takes the mother boxes back
to that little Russian town to start his
apocalypse terraforming picnic the sky
turned blood-red on the surface that red
sky is pure apocalypse Steppenwolf
turning earth into a version of his
reddish world after all but under the
surface that red sky represents very DC
specific levels of doom leading up to
and during the crisis on Infinite Earths
storyline DC comic artists started
coloring the skies red in their other
comic books most of the time that was
the only tie in which is the reason
panels like this showed up in comics
like Swamp Thing so while those red
skies made sense in the movie they also
represented DC's classic way of saying
big things are going down gorilla sign
language if you could give the flash an
iconic nemesis that wasn't another
speedster it would undoubtedly be
Gorilla Grodd a hyper intelligent ape
who's got a hyper personal vendetta
against the flash obviously there
weren't any giant gorillas in Justice
League but there was a mention of that
classic villain I'll be it briefly when
Bruce Wayne tracks down Allan the super
speedster tries to convince Wayne that
he's not really the flash which leads to
this line fluent in sign language
gorilla sign language for fans of the
comics it was immediately obvious that
Allan was referring to Grodd the
greatest gorilla in the DC Universe at
least outside of jackanapes the Joker's
adopted gorilla son but this was much
more likely a sly reference to Grodd
cold resistance and that same scene
where Bruce Wayne first meets Barry
Allen there are a ton of things going on
in the background if you weren't paying
attention to the Rick and Morty episode
you might have noticed something else on
one of those screens look closely at the
monitor directly behind and to the left
of Ezra Miller and pay attention to the
words at the top cold resistance clearly
Barry has been testing his suits
tolerance for a chill and one particular
flash villain comes to mind when you
think of cold captain cold
aka Leonard snart one of Flash's deadly
villains does this mean that flash is
already defeated Captain Cold in this
universe or was he gearing up for a
confrontation when Steppenwolf stepped
on everyone's plans we just don't know
ace chemicals they're a good handful of
Easter eggs and blazoned on the
buildings throughout the film one of
which was a small neon sign advertising
ace chemicals and if you know your
comics history you know where this is
going
yep ace chemicals is the chemical plant
where the Joker fell into a toxic vat
and became well the Joker
it's got my different names and
different versions of the origin story
it was called access chemicals in 1989's
Batman an oddly monarch playing card
company in the original run of Detective
Comics but ace chemicals is now DC Canon
for the name of the birthplace of the
Joker in Justice League the sign is a
blink and you'll miss a detail but it's
a nice touch on the world-building of
the movie Gotham gargoyle
nothing says Batman like standing in a
gargoyle high above Gotham on a dark
stormy night if you could put that image
in a bottle it smell like the inside of
Batman's cowl guaranteed so the shot of
Batman on a Grim Reaper gargoyle and the
Justice League Comic Con trailer was a
definite crowd-pleaser if you've done
your homework can read all gazillion
issues of Detective Comics you might
recognize that Reaper image the shot is
a direct homage to the cover of
Detective Comics number 682 ancient king
after Steppenwolf's first invasion of
earth the three mother boxes were split
among the races the Atlanteans and
Amazon's built cool little shrines for
their boxes but the men being men
decided they couldn't trust anyone so
they buried theirs out in the woods IMDb
only lists the main guy there is the
ancient king of men there's one
particular ancient king of men who
definitely plays a role in the DC
Universe King Arthur most of the
mythological lore of King Arthur is kept
intact in the DCU so it's definitely
possible that he was the one who would
be entrusted with the mother box after a
war that happened hundreds of years ago
super plaid Superman is the worst it
disguises but that's part of who he is
so we're all okay with that by now then
somewhere along the line live-action
adaptations of Superman decided that he
also needed to add plaid to his
repertoire of implausibly common
wardrobe choices maybe it's because he
grew up on a farm in Kansas
that's what farmers wear whatever the
reason old Clarks been putting on plaid
whenever he visits the family farm ever
since 1978 Superman it's usually red but
not always
it was white in Superman four and white
again in Superman Returns Man of Steel
got nervous and put his mom and plaid
but oh there's Clark wearing plaid again
in Batman vs Superman all the way in
Metropolis to
some of his shirts have some of the
plaid in them so there's a little
reminder of the the Midwestern boy from
Kansas and who can forget the CW
Smallville a show that spent more on
plaid than sister acts entire budget for
nun costumes which brings us back to
Justice League where Clark heads out to
the farm in Smallville to talk to Lois
in plaid even though she totally knows
who he is and he can just wear the suit
with the big-ass she just called him
Clark in front of a dozen policemen
while he was super Manning the
Superfriends so why did he change to
plaid
because it's an easter egg look the
bottom line is if you ever see a guy
anywhere wearing plaid there's a 30%
chance it's Superman thanks for watching
click the looper icon to subscribe to
our YouTube channel let's check out all
this cool stuff we know you love to
[Music]